look giving holiday gifts is great hmm
hmm you want that gift baby do I want
that gift I want that sweet gift I'm
talking about hunting oh you want that
honey how you want that drip-drip do I
want that nectar from the bees we're the
babies suck on your own but your
delinquent I might but I also might save
my issues in honey which is a free
browser extension that automatically
finds the best promo codes wherever you
shop online this means you always get
the best deals without even trying over
20,000 sites such as Amazon eBay
Jake Rousseff or Expedia Target Best Buy
and so much more hmm well look I'm
saying this I like sometimes they do the
old-school way where I cut out the
coupons I save on my car I bring them to
the place I was showing give us a coupon
for these costumes honey what costumes
yeah that's how we dress every day bro
honey Sports over 20,000 stores online
honey has over 100,000 five-star reviews
on Google Chrome I know it does do but
I'm talking about what about the coupons
you get the coupon you take it in is
that not how to do it it's not the way
to do it you gotta get honey man honey
can make sure that you're getting the
best price for whatever you're buying
what am i buying like a jet ski forget
the best price just do it online what if
I'm buying one of those fish that like
sings on the wall that you plug in oh
that's that things yeah they might get
to one of those at a good deal I can't
make guarantees I get this hat from
there it's free to use installs in just
two clicks get honey for free at join
honey calm slash cats that's join honey
calm / - honey here's an ad from the
king of the sting dude I need that
freaking cowboy cut brisket at nine
o'clock at night you know who's bringing
it bro I know he's bringing it dude just
reach in your pants who pervert they
look nice bro now you you looking for
that smoked sausage you reach into these
pants bro post mates can help you with
that as well okay you look like fluffle
Oh bill bro you look like somebody you
look like a cowboy that only shows up to
make sure the pillows are comfortable
you're out of your mind man I'm talking
post-military drinks jet fuel settling
shot in a freaking thick handful of
yogurt any a freaking stepmothers
[ __ ] jaw this is what you got to do
man you got to order something legit for
you got a man 24 hours a day 365 days a
year
post mates will bring you what you need
within an hour download the app on your
phone iPhone or Android so 19 browse
local restaurants and businesses and
track your delivery in real time and
right now you want to shovel a bunch of
pie in your stupid face postmates has
given our listeners $100 a free delivery
credit for your first 7 days yeah you
want to batch of oysters for your
cousin's diaper dude you want a couple
of uh you know a couple Chico sticks to
hide and your frickin ass stepmoms
brassiere do it right do it tonight dude
post mates yeah I was like a wrap what
is it right get it right get it tight no
boys I want corn cob in your butthole
anything you need anything you need it
post mates it download the post mates
and save with code k 80s 2019 yup that's
$100 a free delivery get the post movies
don't be that guy don't be doing this
and doing that and yelling out your
window if somebody bring me a sausage
biscuit yeah do something
I think the 1900s brought you to life
right anything you need any time
download post mates and save with the
code k ATS two zero one nine
Hair Spray you have a t-shirt on
we I'm gonna Jack it dude I'm not Nellie
come on Jack with no shirt and chain
underneath you know you look like
freaking Nellie Oleson from Little House
on the Prairie Oh interesting
yeah look like icebox from the Giants
yeah you look like that what's that
movie that more minute MA Mart Ocean's
eleven Brad Pitt thanks dude
where we at no dude first of all you're
the worst mind reader because no I'm not
saying that okay they got Martin
what's-his-name who played uh Oh Martin
Mabel vincible who've played for those
people Polly dude know who played for
the Eagles for one Delbert Rudy
Ruettiger you freaking know it's Vince
Pope Ollie dude Rudy played for Notre
Dame offsides by the way yep
Rudy played for noting Ollie was the
walk done from Philly yep that's what
I'm talking about I look like a giant
Vince but Polly yep I T look like right
I'm growing my hair up to look like him
yeah Mark Wahlberg is small Vince Paw
Paw Paw Paw wasn't that small beautiful
man - Vince well Pauly how many
children's it does he had does it say
now someone said he he had uh six to 205
didn't play any college what hits me the
last cannot play any college boy resides
in Cherry Hill New Jersey oh I've been
to a um a double tree or a Crowne Plaza
over there
ooh with his wife Janet and two children
Gabriella and Vinnie dude he lives in
the Crowne Plaza no he lives in Cherry
Hill me you went to Crowne Plaza they're
saying he lives in a Crowne Plaza Cherry
Hill is a beautiful suburb you know you
almost don't even know you're there
are you Neagle said oh I'm more animal
probably than the Deni group the unified
team my support union workers though
he's like the bird yep not the team I
like the team I just
I like Darren Sproles that's who I like
did you grow up Reggie white fan marry
him
yeah Reggie white Dido all the guns die
Jerome Brown Reggie White
yah Randall Cunningham dad dad dad dad
Jim McMahon Jim McMahon alive doing that
play for the Eagles they need bears and
eagles Jim McMahon played for the Bears
and for do you play for Atlanta think he
finished up with the Eagles no he's only
started the Dirty Bird no yeah look mr.
steal your girl
Eagles Vikings Cardinals my honey no he
had all those last teams he play for
Bears chargers army at charges
definitely all [ __ ] he played for every
team Wow literally if name a team he
played for him he's a legend bro is evil
yeah ya know um what's going on man yeah
that G that thing is bright do you like
a swag you ready for st. Paddy's huh I
guess or an Eagles game you know they
suck dude I think they have a still have
a chance what's their record one in nine
or three and four yeah you're getting
real cocky cuz your teams undefeated
they're not in a feed we lost once who
to the Rams
oh that's right is that one breathes
breezy
Brady went down young breezy and frickin
what's his name Sam Donald hit him in
the thumb the [ __ ] that's how fragile
these quarterbacks are nowadays oh dude
you know one thought you know what just
a thumb you know here a thumb there a
thumb you guys got Bridgewater now huh
hmm bridging the waters dude and it's
all he joining me he's taking a
step-by-step play-by-play yep
he's basically the Paula Abdul of no one
else huh do you know you don't know what
about oh wow dude I feel like we've been
over that dude Derrick was a dude his
dad was busted and his mom when that
song came out or that's an old know
there's that Paul Paula Abdul er is that
Janet Jackson that's Paula Abdul and
that's how Paul I'm doing chester
Cheetah dude Oh Chester cheater
yeah
so he molested another cartoon didn't
have charges against him during that me
to it then yeah he did
he peed on a few adolescents as well
drew it yep that cheeto drip
are you a puff scary crunchy guy sounds
a lot about a person no I do remember
sometimes when I was good when I was
young my grandmother gave me a couple of
them little cheeto balls you know oh
dude that's good he touched me when you
say that's not and they had a big
canister of them it only came in
canisters like they were nuts do it
right here's the thing back in the day
they just used to come in a canister
about this tall and wide no no no this
thing was my grandma had the why that's
when you couldn't Circus barrels yeah
for that this back from military was
still popular and they came in like kind
of like almost like something you would
load in new a okay yeah-oh in the
[ __ ] light up keep hugging yeah like
an M 9,000 now what's that company that
made them cheese balls real early well
that's the generic [ __ ] no see you okay
hey you know asteroids cat not trying to
be out you can apply to young you came
with the young hitter yeah that's way
too young we need original cheese balls
Jerry's on now I would get out I would
get up believably bad yeah it's pretty
bad I'd get a barrel we got planer yeah
that's why I'm saying them peanuts candy
and that you didn't say the cane you
said it big tank yeah you right now
planters had them cheese balls
originally those are the originals damn
you can still buy them 2:29 can you look
up can you wiki these if you don't mind
um know what I like to do I get there a
league my balls people say that all the
time what I like to do is get a can of
those cheese balls and wash it down with
a nice Pepsi Claire really yeah come
home from school do that play a little
NBA Jam with my brother maybe maybe get
in a fight
yeah set some tree on fire you guys
sound like a couple like you on the day
I might as well just have sex with each
other if y'all doing all that gay stuff
can you tell us a little bit more about
the original cheese puffs
feel like you just had it for that was
good that was on there is no like so you
want to look up planter's Cheez balls
I can't believe can still buy and those
things will
you teeth um planners cheese balls
original do original or plaster hit
history or God's sakes between the two
of you man [ __ ]
planters Wikipedia right there to get
them cheese balls discontinued and
reintroduced well look at the [ __ ]
old school poster planners was found by
the Italian immigrant did not know
there's a hot lady right there
giving you them ball can you find the
cheese balls on their their slogans well
there you go
discontinued Rindge cheese puffs cheese
balls
she click on that hitter right there on
that link 1936 nuts cheese whiz cheetos
cheetos cheese toes cheese curls
i'm not familiar with these now are the
common no look common browns if all
those are cheese puffs so at first hit
the USA in 1948 mmm beautiful mmm those
were the days man those were the days
get a handful them balls and they only
had two or three types of chips then
they had a potato chip ruffle ruffle had
ridges and that was the craziest thing
ever
he saw some a girl with those dude they
was doing sitting there back to the
future you know they had ruffles in the
40s ooh
not the fort we weren't alive in the
forties we weren't be can imagine would
be like if you had ruffles walking down
the streets break a couple out you know
shoes but you had a couple rock oh my
god do barefoot in the street hustle
house baby [ __ ] trap house keep that
ruffle house God if you were crazy back
then have you ever seen potatoes like
these lady you see yeah yeah she suck
these ball still you look like
definitely an Irish bird just came all
over you Brian that coat
Irish birds come yeah they do dude
didn't hear the last episode when it was
urinating on that lady
yeah you're right dude you gotta pay a
little extra for it but they'll do it oh
but dude yeah for 80 cents brah you know
a no Heron will come all over you brah
I'm not mad at that Jersey dude it's
King in a sitting man
yeah we could do those again with some
pretty dope they are nice like this
coming out soon for the road
no well not this look like a varsity
jacket Farsi varsity varsity has a
Persian crowd I'm like let me go with
that they say we're selling rugs for
this specific man
I like Eagles are like bald eagles I
like now my favorite birds and a lot of
people don't know it is the let me guess
ready yep
pigeon no vulture perky do can Kiwi no
seagull oh I like a nice clean seagull
myself nope Pelican same thing kind of
you know no different has its own name
so they named it something special
because it's a special bird of God it is
a special get a damn Pelican if it's a
water bird it is a water bird as they
get now are you just saying cuz hitting
a water bird nowhere when pelicans bro
huh well yes stupid name for a team then
pecans dog you know but look at some
information on there those are images
unbelievable dude we've really we well
we know they Pelican Wikipedia right
here the long beak the large throat long
thought to be related to forgettable
what does that say Derek if you don't
mind there's a frigate birds amen for
gate birds or cormorants also known as
spoonbills they're also known to be able
to deep throat anything in the water did
imagine brah they used to be they used
to carry messages to in World War two
more War three now World War two
probably yeah right just
mm oh yeah but well I can fast a big
bird huh Sian Williams out six to eight
weeks he's heading started but also get
smaller like you're too big oh he could
be the Gregor or sadly he could be the
thick right out no Greg goal in the
Benjamin Button the players when they
showed me in hot is showed me him in
high school Mike that's a 47 year old
man you get a beard gray hairs
401k
but hey that's a good point but he could
be I mean I'm just worried like all that
hype and stuff they had him Duncan for
the children every other day in the
afternoon over there in New Orleans
that's all he does is dunk for charity
yeah blew out his [ __ ] ACL bro blew
out the kids yeah dunk for your own kid
yeah so who knows what will happen man
but that's crazy to start your whole
career six-day was extremely dangerous
huh how many of those players bounce
back he's having straight-up surgery on
his knee
six to eight weeks man yeah it's a while
dude I'll tell you what MBAs never been
better man there's like eight teams you
might win it you know I'm saying it
never been better since when we were
kids I was like Jordan Isaiah right now
it's poppin' is it now New Orleans ain't
gonna do [ __ ] this year and that's not a
big deal but in LA you live here so you
can cheer for either team be a
fair-weather fan yeah like honestly I
like New Orleans yeah he's out for ankle
fixed yeah he said oh you know it
surgery uh surgery they screwed about
that boy too thick
like Charles Barkley do you think he
might be man thank you
dude I might uh buddy - asking about
investing in a zoo actually in Mexico in
Sinaloa I've been there
Sinaloa yeah oh man they don't have any
issues out there you should definitely
do that well some of its beachside I
think if you look it up I don't know I
don't know if the end of the visa I know
a cartel would be the main issues there
that's why they need people to come in
and do this hold up you think you're
opening a zoo and sanella
Mexico and you don't think gotta grease
the palms the cartel there bro you think
you're bringing in zebras and you're
bought the vet these are you think
you'll have to grease the palms of the
underworld you think you're bringing a
bearded lizard pass out chapo and you
don't have to grease the [ __ ] palms
daddy got your goddamn I'm bro dude I
look don't worry it's not I don't know a
buddy am I got a read on an animal
investor got a dude get a read and open
it somewhere close to us man all invest
of its 148 hundred to get in bro can you
give me any information
Derek give
Louisa's here but can help him out
Louise Wow how dude he's racist right
I thought you told me you were yesterday
what are you what are you what are you
Louise I [ __ ] called it dude didn't
call anything son whose native Amer okay
okay you kept calling Mexican I didn't I
respect them and just kept it very [ __ ]
you man
yeah Latino yeah do you know whatever
there yeah whatever dude
it says but either way your name from
Mexico he knows it's a bad idea open up
any he's from America okay
have some respect battle bro you open up
of fighting petting zoo they're either
you know saying it here petting zoo you
ass well it's a sanctuary for anomalous
will you give us some information
Derrick it's apparently not safe to be
there for foreigners very risky and
don't be out at night the most well
naive the most risky Americans can't go
there you dumb ass turn and open up all
white people zoom it's a daddy zoo zoo
it's not a night say what this seems
like a [ __ ] cover-up for sex
trafficking that's what it sounds like
zoo I come zoo's a horrible idea to
animals get frisky dude what do you want
otherwise these animals are gonna be
coming up here looking for her it was a
pro we need to take care of these
animals on their home court hit up
Whitney Cummings if you have a giraffe
send it over right now the air quality's
bad today if the other hippo let me know
I'll bring my truck I'll be at the
corner of Highland and La Cienega
tonight take it all emus and larger
that's what won her votes it please no
snakes dude here's what I'm saying
Sinaloa beautiful daytime you need is
there any images if you click on Sinaloa
how about this first thing that pops up
showered in a blaze of bullets yes no
you're not openers you there [ __ ]
click on an image they're all burning
truck hey you know what you should do
open open a [ __ ] petting zoo in Syria
right now
dude hey this isn't the spot hold on I
just burped I do want to open up
actually a company like a cling-wrap
company in Syria calls Syrian wrap no we
didn't whatever dude
well listen to this man animals deserve
love everywhere and I think do it Dan
forty-eight Hyundai you know and I know
it's expensive but to know that animals
are doing well there and hope then one
of the whole city's on fire which one
you live on right in the middle
oh that's where they're people that down
like that one oh it's just a bunch of
dead bodies that's a bunch of dead
bodies that were put in the river yeah
it's time oh there's snow when the mix
was most violent States but you know
what makes people relax and calm down
guinea pigs see I mean Molly's anomalous
oh look at that she buys your guns away
man for his the roads today homes yeah I
like lambs steel Vaughn's camera over
here bro yeah bro ooh look the Rat King
have a [ __ ] a porcupine up here
porcupine and the awesome man well look
man sorry I want to invest in Mexico
dude no that's how it happens people
wanna invest in Mexico they get turned
down by guys wearing the Eagles jacket
but doesn't want support egoless huh the
Eagle is a-- what about the O do I like
my flamingo hey are there Eagles in
Mexico Mexican Eagles look it up Mexican
eagle nope bald eagle
I assume he's the America's logo because
of you can only get him here unlike any
bravery I found throughout the world the
bald eagles found only only in North
America you [ __ ] get so goddamn red
white and blue only found in North
America dude that's there that's the
Mexican eagle right there no hold up it
says the ball don't hold up the bald
eagle only found in North America bald
eagles are found throughout most of the
North America from Alaska Canada how
fantastic that nobody ain't seen that
other part there we go well Louisa's
from Central America dude yeah dude you
kept calling Mexican I
body's here yesterday well he led me to
believe some things oh hey Central
America believe in ghosts spirit day
yeah hablo pop a/c that's about all the
Spanish I have yeah for mayor white
camera guy ghost amen
your momma and Poppa believe up yep yeah
your mom does you don't know if his
mother does it cuz he's white don't pick
on him all right everybody deserves a
[ __ ] chance bro
everybody do yeah man so look man good
luck with the petting zoo in Mexico dude
it's not for petting dude and they need
better PR for Sinaloa man oh yes sir
dude flames and a lot of these initial
images let's keep this thing frickin
yeah let's kick this [ __ ] off kick this
[ __ ] husband light you up first we got
Matt Smith from Texarkana Oh Matt from
Texas Arcana
that you do please and that bit of gun
what do you say Chevy or Ford I'm stupid
listen to that bishop gun Chevy or Ford
let's go through it trucks I gotta go
with for that f-150 is just so goddamn a
richer now you feel me I like some of
their theme songs too who had the one
lock rock I was proud as I could be I
can I got somebody just breastfeeding
their daddy right there there's some
white with some white family unloading
hold up dude it was only white people in
like a rock there was no black family in
that baby black I was like trucks man
they do I love trucks however Ford like
a rock commercial was the widest thing
of all time let's watch a little bit of
it look at a white guy in the front
footing but America is still the land of
the Chevy Chevy lounging racist not the
lady is from 1892 if we go back and look
around she dress like let's get but hey
she loved his trucks bro no she doesn't
she's stuck actually that almost stuck
in there it looks like a male honestly
that almost looks like a man man
no that's oh that's a female actually
young lady that's a young lady obviously
doing some work outside with crops yeah
juice everybody walk in a tight line but
this is the commercial that I am looking
at you're a young black lady you're
perpetuating crops that what you're
perpetuating rowdyism drop flowers crops
could be anything like a rock corn where
are you going at with this D could be
corn could be like a rock they're
talking about crack
first of all back to the one I guy oh
let's go back to the one I think I have
one night what really people do Brendan
who casted this thing couldn't Tarantino
what's going on here why is the 1% one
line okay right there okay now look at
that guy tatted up hand so I got a lot
of questions you might be right unlike a
rock now guys had a long night he worked
on the morning I had one I left he's
doing his best dude
so I'm saying I'm gonna go maybe with
Chevy trucks yeah the kind of switch
things up cuz commercials pretty bomb
yeah I'm trying to think of us forward
someone the Ford is the rock now built
for 200 built Ford Tough built would go
to Ford commercial but if now if we're
going cars are you not selling cars well
just well he didn't say trucks
he didn't just said Ford or Chevy I
don't know let's keep it if we don't
mind trucks just alcohol the pickups in
the market today it's the leader board
I'll just think their most famous
commercial they didn't have a hitter I
don't know if they had like a big a big
theme song I can't think of any Ford
commercial Oh Alan Jackson for country
go to that one right
not the night yes this is it dude you
tell me which one
[Music]
do this I'm buying a for right now
looking down below look at that truck
yeah they switched it up dude come on
let's see what's in the video there's
Allen hell yeah that was him singing
right got Persian guy right guys all
right so I got a Persian dope that's I'm
homoerotic like Oh black worker that guy
look like you had a truck Chevy suspect
I'm going I'm back on Ford now I'll go
forward man I'm going forward uh yeah uh
oh dude what hit me more time with it
who was it long as I could be Lara now
let me hit you with I've been drinking
tea luck okay
well I'm kind of into it but now
remember Ford hit you would he's gone
country so country you know who loves
country is chin I'm not just all about
the United State does guard broke gar
bro I'm going forward
Allen Jax I'm gonna go with Chevy let's
see what they picked 51% Chevy whoa hey
race no you're freakin audience [ __ ]
goon thank you for bringing that in
young man great [ __ ] question up next
this is a Kirby Sloan from Toronto yeah
the Rat King hitter on what up Brendan
what up Theo it's currently first
Toronto guy debate club for you guys
what do you guys prefer comedy or horror
movies let me know big Wang pose pose
ooh big Wang pubs dubs
I'm a horror fan I live for horror
movies I love all of them all of them
are you scared in the movies I like the
old-school horror movies we talked about
it for Jason or Freddy and stuff like
that yeah [ __ ] those but like what else
comedy movies
well yeah if you go through [ __ ] like
right now horse popping horror movies
are huge man
like did you see the ones that kind of
kicked off Mary Blair Witch Project oh
yeah that was 20 years ago
now I'm saying I kind of kicked
everything off now you got the car
drinks I'm talking about real real
horror movies you don't tell my grow
very own movies that's a point real wait
am i growing up around diabetes dude I
don't need horde it is good I go outside
and have to fight off animals fight off
[ __ ] rare owls with [ __ ] with with
diseases in their beaks okay Brendan mmm
out here living is freaking he whose
life was yeah movie watching horror
movies inside dude I'm outside they got
a snake boy and they got two different
things that will get you
that's that movie anaconda JLo no dude
that's a horror movie that's outside
that's Tuesday morning acid Eiffel
you're running a school and one of your
friends gets [ __ ] attacked by a
[ __ ] Gator you don't know [ __ ] boy
[ __ ] boy I'm a horror fan yeah sounds
like it dude yeah one of your favorite
movies horror movies probably
transformers I'm gonna vote huh I'm
saying comedy movies I guess dude I'm
going horse this topics too big it's too
big bring a small topic get appreciate
your your support but bring a small
topic do you don't bring it what's the
fan say 85% comedy yeah geez you don't
bring a big topic to a small topic fight
going to pay the booze do I tell you
what I wish I use manscape I put this
freaking outfit on gym manscape that
outfit right off your body
sure bro cuz I got a bush out the front
do you I got a bush hanging out the
front because I didn't use manscape cuz
I'm sick of sneaking my balls every time
I trim up bro yeah yeah you your balls I
guess I've really been really abused
yeah they've been beating around black
guys a couple of black guys man well
look dude are you sure bro because you
can't just jump to conclusions anymore
yeah you right okay Jesse small yeah
poor for King and the sting comes from
manscaped
and manscape is number one and below the
belt grooming your legs your nuts your
back your taint your behold your back
jaw whatever you got dude you want a
drug mule clean up your [ __ ] body
first you got that duck tail hanging off
the top of your butt snip it dude yeah
you're nuts look like they've been
living out in the woods for freaking six
months dude tighten them up bro that's
got a dreads in a ponytail tighten
get 20% off free shipping with code cats
at manscaped yeah your penis looking
Yiddish out there trim them sideburns
off your freaking deep like a
Rastafarian pumps it off and free
shipping with the code cats at manscape
calm yes 20% free shipping at manscape
trying to pee but your wiener won't take
the joint out of its mouth because it's
listening to too much no no right
snip it messy trim that [ __ ] Peter
brah get 20% off on free shipping with
the code Kay 80s manscape com get your
package legit trying to keep lights on
scrubs scrubs no no no no yes yes don't
want no scrub yes you do do you no
scrubs look terrible dude I'm sick of
the type these poor nurses and doctors
and dentists they look ridiculous
they look ridiculous in these scrubs
there needs to be some dope scrubs for
them well that's what I'm saying
scrub-a-dub-dub do cuz the company's
finally here and these people called
figs fi GS like the fruit yup and my
sister is getting these for Christmas
even though she doesn't know it do not
tell her uh cats out of the bag enjoy
those [ __ ] that's what she wants to do
this is a you know it's feminist time
bro you're right dude for years nurses
and doctors and dentists and other
awesome medical professionals were
forced to wear scratchy ill-fitting
scrubs it really look like SpongeBob
SquarePants and blue yeah I need more
now you guys are swagged out every set
of figs is don't look at me yeah stylist
people are like oh is that I'm a
supermodel putting an IV in my arm now
that's still a nurse man dude is my is
my doctor and some skinny job yeah he is
but he's asking a fix your back yep
scrub a dub the newest scrubs are from a
company called figs fi GS and my sister
is a nurse down here in Baton Rouge and
she gonna get these for Christmas and
they did some nice gift if you have
somebody in the medical profession
dentist oh you know great all
dermatology electricians 90 I'm gonna
buy him these just so he looks super
swaggy
yeah he's creeping everybody out
anything nurse registered nurse
unregistered nurse dude somebody working
the graveyard shift
maybe you just want to look smart yeah
you might not even have a job but you
want to look you want to look like a
would you want your tinder profile look
like you're working at doctors buy these
scrubs you know like super swaggy so
whether you're one of the awesome humans
that worked in health care or someone
that wants to say thanks to these
deserving folks figs is gonna make that
easy by providing you guys with 15% off
your first purchase by using the code
tats you know quit thinking don't think
too hard or think too much because you'd
think oh I'm await I'm gonna get them up
you know a snow globe or I'm gonna get
them this you know of lost lamp
yeah crystal power not even out yet we
haven't designed they haven't even done
any of that so what I'm saying is head
to where figs w8e a are fi GS calm and
enter our code k a TS yeah don't let
Beyonce Destiny's Child put a bad name
on Scrubs do ya scrub yeah you don't
know but yes yes yes yes someone's got
to pay for Brennan's coffee habit this
is Matt banks from st. Louis Matt bakes
for st. Louis videos a little great
shirt bro yo Theo Brennan got a new
debate club question for you this week
he's them TV guys watching movies again
to myself which of these two actors have
the better collection of films
Will Ferrell or Ben Stiller we're
talking old school versus Meet the
Parents anchorman versus Tropic Thunder
Road thing versus done by gang gang cuz
cuz and that seemed like one of the
newer ways horror films kind of the way
that they had yeah that was like Blair
Witch - mm-hmm look pretty dope if you
ask me uh what's he asking well he's an
outdoorsman you can see he's got a bike
in the back is a bike helmet also also
endures rain because a bunch of comic
stuff in the back you know Will Ferrell
or Ben Stiller movies so you got let's
go through a couple Ben Stiller Meet the
Parents something about Mary Tropic
Thunder Gable man directed and wrote
bronze
uh-oh dodgeball Oh Ben
New Orleans what am I thinking who
Landor knighted that what else oh you
met Trey Anastasio bio biopic
I know what else he's in a knot Along
Came Polly uh yeah Heartbreak Kid
Hades gonna walk a mile away now you go
through Will Ferrell guys last night
he's our bombers but yeah a lot of
freaking moms did Step Brothers was good
I would go with Ben Stiller man for me
Oh like mass like overall yeah look at
Ben Stiller's career compared to Will
Ferrell's will feel how I like
stepbrothers hitter anchorman SNL we had
if you can't well Ben Stiller show on
Comedy Central was huge but you can't
just SNL it's on a show we're start
about movies I think for some quality of
work for movies yeah well it will feel
like okay anchorman that president
Crashers
the campaign stepbrothers
campaign holiday good night honey as was
pretty good oh yes whoo lander he still
isn't that too though yeah he's the main
guy so that's a wash they're both in
that that dating move over Ben Stiller
gets all sweaty that time at the dance
oh that's good I'm gonna go with this
cellar I know that's that's something
out Mary then still are all day people
gonna say well fail but 84% welfare yeah
that's that's these that's like that's
something it's easy it's like that's and
that's a perfect example of how
something's wrong with us I prize
you put those two when you really think
it out I do think it's Benson you do the
body of work now who do I think it's
probably funnier
I think it's Will Ferrell but who dry
things out a better probably career
overall decent movies were actually like
watch didn't been like all this is
pretty this here's the other thing Ben
Stiller escape of denim denim era the on
Showtime wanna you wanna us or was with
it you want to Emma for is it any good
haven't seen it it's amazing is it
really so dope yeah alright man let's
just you know you think we'll fair over
there yeah even though we just list out
all those movies he's Ron Burgundy bro
ah that but you say one movie yeah but
then it's the movie how interesting I
see I that to me too as grown up with
something about Mary's more important
than anchorman some
Mary was I mean that's that's the movie
they should do something was something
about the Marines and it's like all
sneaky stories about something I haven't
different men in there that'd be cool
and Will Ferrell's in it
Ben Ben Stiller yeah there's something
bout the Mohicans benzos never had a
movie like that Sherlock Watson movie
which was just a [ __ ] encyclopedia
brown bitty that's a serious movie
though yeah not comedy that comes out
movie but Ben sirs never had to miss
with comedy
look guys looked at it later too is
definitely huge myth yep
and Joe Dirt 2 wasn't that great even
though if you say to David Spade II does
not he does not want to hear that they
should have left it alone sure they
directly yeah I may what I have you and
Joe Dirt I have no idea I don't know
your dirt six dude you know I'm saying
heaven versus hell
Tim dirt and you're in it dude
yeah good Joe or Joe's over yeah his
stepbrother Tim Timmy or damp dirt dirt
damp dirt dry dirt
yeah dry dirt what else we got we got a
little flow our boys Oh finally get some
finally Sheri is god damn I'm Sheri and
boats and Ho's boats and Ho's every time
I come up reduce it court and where she
from Louisiana
she had Sheree is from the East Coast
didn't say what city just North Carolina
nevermind oh yeah Tar Heels she's 46 and
a mom of three and a hairdresser
mm-hmm do my hair I'd curl her hair with
my with my desires mmm my god curlers he
owns that motor that's a released boat
I had soom she owns that so yeah well
her man does yeah she is all mmm she's
all natural too huh
oh yeah you think those tits look real
real uni in the middle they don't under
on the right they look like maybe you
know in the middle younger pick on the
right looks like maybe get some floats
done you feel me yeah a little air
floats
I'm not mad at this moment oh that's a
southern belle
a Tar Heel that's that Carolina barbecue
sauce you feel me mmm-hmm full rock-hard
titty to [ __ ] yeah allow that up with
that Carolina mustard barbecue you like
that hard titty mm-hmm you like that
hard titty boy setup to this mom [ __ ] a
cement Tita [ __ ] cement a DJ Alois you
[ __ ] check out this mom dude
yeah about time we got that iron and
drywall tt no joking man beautiful lady
what's her name Sheri aren't you Jerry
yeah no sure she has three children
she's obviously mothering out there so
I'll tell you what's in them titties
milk brother because he's been out there
taking care of some little ones looking
fine on that so a long time ago dude I'd
go home with that lady just a freaking
sneak out in the middle of night and go
sit in that boat and have a cigarette
yeah I'd like to talk about some brisket
some Carolina put some meat on your
grill
Chapel Hill baby I'm all over it
that's wifey son now she seemed like a
great woman yes she does up next this is
aunt Harriet please don't aunt Harriet
amen
is this for Halloween oh I don't know
she's from Central Texas that's all we
know this is not for a lloween brother
this Central Texas man they just dressed
like that yeah huh okay he is a service
woman it's aunt Harriet dude she'd be
filled a service woman in the world and
probably not protecting our borders very
well semper female bro she's getting it
done bro Semper Fi man ah can you zoom
in is there anything on those badges
something's going on here do they leave
anything else is she protecting a Red
Robin what's going on GI Georgia oh well
set the beach enjoying life this [ __ ]
is out there protecting the [ __ ]
popsicle stand she definitely seems like
the angriest person at the where you
pick up your kids after school
the most serious bug didn't carpool ah
duty she seems like the most serious
carpool duty worker let's get a woman's
take cat do you feel like this woman is
a service woman which was also a very
strong possibility or do you think she's
playing dress-up I don't know something
about this looks off but the look in her
eyes make me feel like she's done some
[ __ ] oh she's not [ __ ] around right
now she might just beat your ass at a
Red Robin though she has the right camo
in though you know like she blends into
that sand you see look at the lower half
where'd she go boom sand cow camo Sam
Sann camo now who's behind her I want to
see some of these people her behind her
there's a woman looking at a jacket now
there's another military hat back behind
her is she like the reserves and there's
another military person even further
back behind them if you look right there
that guy looks like he's running cuz he
left his gun well whatever he's doing
yeah she picked it up something's going
on honey maybe it's like a hey come out
and spend a day with the troops and she
like got all dressed up her child could
be serving and she's out there doing
that deal you know I think look barb
what's her name Harriet Harriet not
buying that bro you got to have a gun to
defend that name against people to do
people come out of Harriet
everybody thinks Harriet wants to
[ __ ] fight Harriet Tiffany I'll tell
you what I'm not step on here it's
[ __ ] lawn
she likes pasto your ass bro oh yeah
trim your nuts yeah with that gun you
got to nades on her belt just ship
tunde's on they're probably wired gloves
so big the clothes do look a little gone
you know I don't she's an extra from
Starship Troopers old movie Derek beam
me out of here man beam me out of this
one good luck to this lady fair luck
area thank you yeah good luck you're
defending a might be out of like a civil
war which might be defending a lane
Bryant somewhere too
right what's a women's clothing store
made well or oh she might be protected
forever 21 yeah yeah but in an adult
woman not someone know she wants to be
21 forever oh and she's pissed I could
see that they don't have clothes for
what else you got
this or last night this is aunt violet
we started out great and then we [ __ ]
unfollow from the giant eagle and I got
a bj back behind him on an M what's a
giant eagle its ironically you should
know it it's a grocery store with your
Eagles jacket on it's a girl store in
the south dude this is an angel species
episode right here bro I might invest in
that zoo yeah oh this is giving me some
signs
aunt Harriet the black girl in the Chevy
commercial this lady the first you
weren't signs giant eagle the Eagles
jacket you're right
you know what's going on with a sad
she's single she ain't she no longer
works at Giant Eagle he actually singles
fancy what's up boys hmm assuming she's
hauling it feel I like your hair Conor
her haircut looks a little bit haunted
you know she looks a little bit like a
Farley brother and it is Halloween so uh
he's like a Farley brother you don't
think so I think she looks like a pretty
lady man you could tell that she she
takes care of herself and she just
saying she you don't think she looks
like will you know I'm saying will
Farley no no no I'm talking about Chris
Farley Oh Chris Farley's I don't know
man
cat what do you think similar mmm they
look like they could be related I don't
know if I would say that she looks like
a sister brother no no a sister she's a
nice lady
Ben Stiller was and there's something
about married to I've said that three
times now but do you say it out loud
it's in your head out loud when I said
that was what did it for me some about
me I wanna hear that can't compete with
Ben if we're gonna back that will fill
can't compete with vents no it should be
Jim Carrey Ben snow if you look at
longevity of careers or Adam Sandler
Will Ferrel don't have a law
list of movies not compared to those two
guys they've been doing it way longer
dude who is the uh who's the black Will
Ferrell do you give any insight onto
that Derrick right and who's the Asian
Will Ferrell I want to know agent will
fill Chan what black will probably
either backup Martin Lawrence or like
somebody gonna run like Jamie Foxx like
in common before maybe I started with
dramas just like a long run I like that
and who do you think is the Asian uh Ben
Stiller the Asian Will Ferrell if there
is one I'm just trying to think you know
people we know that we you know that
stuff I don't know about no I think the
only Asian person that can even compete
in terms of their film career is gonna
be Jackie Chan yeah but I don't know if
he would be either of the two what about
the guy that they have it's in the
hangover to which I funny comedian Ken
Jong right yeah people think of him
funny
been fun no this guy is uh I think he
looks at Owen Wilson ken Jeong oh Ken
Jeong yeah the one you showed his dick
yeah who else but you but you're you're
ripping off the elf brings in a list
there you don't like you hate it okay
let's get into it what are we asking
them would she want relationship advice
here oh yeah
I'll see you out back at the GE darlin
you got yeah you had a little you had
relations by the G I'll see you at that
Cinna low and zoom I love you know I'll
see you back there in the freezer
section you know I'm gonna get polar
bear and you can freakin frisk me let's
go Oh Dex boys we have a little wet
better dead this is what we have done
listen forever
hey Brendon hey Theo its Deanna Rhode
Island I have a web better dead for you
wrestling style China
Miss Elizabeth or Stefaniuk man so let
me know what you guys think Gang Gang
buzz buzz love the podcasts Brendon get
your ass to New England cuz you never
come to our area and we would love to
have you love you guys don't touch me
that keep touching me touch them
okay have you been doing Mary you seem
like a nice girl mom thank you I have
been in New England Brendan oh well I'm
not I'm trying to be shooting here but
dead would be China right because
already dead hate to be shitty she's
already dead so that's kind of fair now
we're down to chew and Stephanie McMahon
for God's sakes
if daddy runs the company heavy on the
man with jr. uh oh yeah yeah I agree
lose the attitude you know China also
did pornography says she might be doing
in it you might want to bid her really
again she passed you know yeah but we're
talking about living probably oh if she
was are alive it's a tough one to get by
um definitely China cuz I'm I'm into
dudes so there's that okay that's kind
of the big one here's that meaty
exterior yeah you think she probably
wears a Ralph Lauren Polo remember when
you stopped doing steroids she doubled
down for life yeah dude
sketches there's army legs god I would
go probably miss Elizabeth for sex
that's the best picture we got is she
from she was she for shoes from the
eighties amazing yeah oh yeah she was I
like the like a promoter kind of like
she'll be a cheerleader outside the ring
never truly a trainee McMahon wasn't she
- with the guy with the mouth of the
South that was her he lifts her up yeah
oh I'm definitely gonna Steffi McMahon
okay I would probably marry stuffing man
I do love with uh I do love with
Elizabeth and I would probably see China
at the funeral parlor you know and I
would I would be there for the female I
get there early yeah go I'd go early
check it out
who are you listen I'm just I'm just
marrying [ __ ] stuff in big man the
other two I could die I think well you
have to pick Brendan because that's the
thing okay I'm marrying Stephanie
McMahon and then sex with the 80s chick
in the middle and then killing the dude
on the right there's a lariat bro what
else you got we got the relationship
advice how do you know he'll be here
myself
oh man you want I'm okay yeah yeah P
yourself no they see you pee yourself
alright what do you got man
we got Devin Hayley Devin ailing Hayley
from Raleigh North Carolina okay let's
see what this young fellas into not him
so fellas boy Devin from Raleigh North
Carolina here gang brother need some
relationship advice someone been talking
to this girl for just a little bit and
she seems great great personality I can
hold a conversation which is very nice
you have a lot of things in common but
we just started talking and basically
she seems to be very busy she's taking a
lot of classes for grad school as well
as working a lot and we on the weekends
as well sometimes from 8:00 to 8:00 on
Saturday and Sunday that's a lot
I get the busy schedule cuz I'm I'm
working myself as well as taking classes
so it's not easy but I'm just wondering
if having these thoughts already so
early in a stalking stage is even worth
considering dating her at all so I just
need some help from you guys whether I
should keep pursuing or if I should just
move on love you guys love everything
you do
slang gang bust up I was expecting seems
like real up upright citizen you know I
like this guy this is a legit advice
question here's the thing I always need
more details when it comes to this dude
to help them out because how old is she
because when I was in college there's no
class on Saturday Sunday
so she 8 to 8 a member who I'm saying
that's tough to buy brother but a lot of
women these days you know they get they
you know this is a feminism time dude
you got women going back to school women
doing you know log cutting you got women
doing their Navy SEALs office yeah you
know but you know Steve you know making
cocaine inch it's getting different dude
women are climbing up you'll see a woman
open your window
somebody's climbing by you know like Oh
where's she going you knows washing your
window angry you should be just dudes
well yeah it was just more risky now
these women are being more risk takers
and it takes more time out of their day
Brendon yeah you in to what I'm saying
is that I just say you say to her hey
babe you know you seem like a nice cool
lady
let's um if you I'd like to take you out
if you're free you let me know because
you
seem busy that's what I'd say yeah I
would say what window are you open if
you're working Monday through Sunday I'm
not buying a girl hey no one's that busy
that busy well let's ask can't because
she's a female and she went to USC I
mean it does seem a little weird cuz I
don't know anybody who has classes on
Saturday for that long unless you have
something very specific I used to have
those days on certain parts of my
semester but that's cuz I'm a theatre
student and I had to be there I don't
know if she's actually that busy well
she might have a learning disability on
the same scope I think that if she's
actively trying to make up not make up
credits make up for like missed out
gates then she clearly wants to spend
time with him if you're that busy and
you continuously try to go see him then
I think now you might have the next
freaking Kylie Jenner on your hands
she's gonna be a billionaire it's pretty
soon she'll be hustling to make that
Bank yeah that's him right up for the
sunset make a bunch of babies dude yeah
so I need more facts on home I solve
this case he seemed like a nice guy this
guy real nice hat trick is that his name
post though does it look like a Defen no
looks like a brad yeah it does yeah
brighter come on Colin or none hell
hmm well good luck dude good luck dude
you can always come down to the zoo and
work with me we will find some animals
make some time for you you know I'll see
you buddy uh I want I want in on the zoo
now though I'll see you bye the tigress
it's Tigers boy one more jela you can
make him babysit the one eagle we're
gonna have them yeah let me just take
care of that massive eagle we got one
more relationship guys this is a Adam
from Charlotte North Carolina is Adam
coming for relationship I've met Adam
actually what's up Bo and Brandon this
is Adam coming from Charlotte North
Carolina got some relationship advice
North Carolina asked recently been
talking to this girl that got out of a
serious relationship and
she come up she comes over a lot and she
cries a lot
yup and I've been trying to console her
and try to make her feel better but her
name's at the ocean party hard Brendon
what a find cries a lot because he's on
[ __ ] special medication for his
illness laid it out well kidding roar
keep trying to comfort her but I kind of
feel like a [ __ ] doing that yeah that's
the right move I can relate to that
start a podcast bro that's all I can
tell you we're keep doing what I'm doing
and you know I don't know if it's
working so let me know what you guys
think
gangbang bust nut another bust nuts and
gangbang dude shoutout to this dude and
she's a con see crying you got a real
Debbie down on your hands can't be that
excited to see if she's constantly
crying to me when girls cry it's kind of
sexy kind of a turn-on
I don't know what that is Christ
something my childhood I need to figure
out talk to therapist about but maybe I
[ __ ] this guy about it but he's gone
see crying things ain't going well man
well salt water can give you an erection
dude I grew up around a lot of brackish
flow myself brother saltwater croc get
me hard um yeah what she's crying at the
house and he's trying to make the
relationship strong she won't stop
crying
she just gotta have a relationship and
now she won't every time she hangs out
but she just cries the whole time
yeah then at this point it sounds like
you're just kind of be gonna be a buddy
you know like it for the for the seat
for the real deal for this stuff I think
at this point maybe you get a nice
outfit you know do something nice for
yourself buy yourself a nice hat buy
yourself a nice shirt pair of j's oh no
by yourself okay you know uh cuff
cummerbund get it out there and look
fresh do something else bro you'd be
supportive of her but you can't be her
um you know yeah you're not a therapist
dude don't be her punching bag you know
I'm saying don't be the kleenex bucko
man yeah man [ __ ] tired luck dude but
dude I Love You Man and I'm hoping if
listen and God loves a crybaby don't
work out you'll find somebody else yeah
and it's nice that you that you're
willing to be there for her for a while
yeah you're a nice guy man but just
don't be there forever dude you got [ __ ]
to do too no one likes a crybaby you got
to live your life yep
get her some dunkaroos total shut the
[ __ ] up this is it your this isn't
parenting techniques
okay let's hoping you cut that I don't
know man it's kind of liven it up up in
here you feel me well this show ever end
you know what are we doing here is it
boys first this is chase and breed well
and Nick Longbottom from Cincinnati Ohio
on bottom from Cincinnati hit them sub
son watch this
hey bro you catch me ridin dirty that's
a sound perm boy that's some rap that's
when that jock jams is your stylist you
know say wow look at that fur bottom
front baby look at that candy apple
inside yeah those guys super swaggy Oh
King King King I don't know where you
can get those two 12 inch subs anymore
well those are twelves I think they come
twelve son twelve to be Dora yeah twelve
thousand do you see now you see how much
shake was in that thing there's an on a
neutron son more shake than a [ __ ] at
a Jamba Juice dude this guy's gotta
buddy's got motor oil in his mustache -
I got a new fave this guy was my fav
this guy sucks start a [ __ ] Honda
Civic brah this guy ain't joking right
here dude man a decent American man hey
well yeah Brendan now I got a I got a
few question I'd like to see the outside
I think he's put all his money into the
speaker's inside I gotta be honest I
don't think this is a car I think this
is almost just like a little space in
the yard or any I don't think things a
hobby yeah I think it's almost just like
a weed station because if you look at
this bar that we see right here on the
top left that red bar just even is you
don't have to play the video right there
yeah that's some sort of um
supporting those speakers oh it could be
some sort of special hovel where this
guy really has some decent sound he's
back in the day gangsters used to have
the boom the 12 this could buy base hits
I forget things called base on and
you're gonna date an underage girl and
you're gonna not move away from town if
you have this system yeah yeah give me
drinking the Mike's Hard Lemonade and
drive around town sad you're gonna be
making
Mike's Hard Lemonade they're all over
town yeah Mike's gonna hide I'm never
gonna leave town you're gonna get your
ass beat by a lot of local dads it
should actually be in that section of
the store hey you wanna get your ass
beat by a local parent by these twelve
shove this guy don't know where you get
that done these days Best Buy used to do
it place called Shack City used to do it
my hood and let's go to the culture
corner because this is something that's
hot in Asian culture and blast yeah yeah
what are we Norman black ting chin you
had speakers in your car yeah [ __ ] yeah
Wow big time huh what did you have 12 Oh
daddy damn it's 27 worth bro fast and
furious chin over here
Ludacris you're a race for pink slips
chin because you have so many goddamn
speakers in it or all your friends were
in it you live your life 1/4 mile at a
time bro
amen brother right on dude [ __ ] King
this loud speakers you don't see it
enough anymore yeah praise God brought
race hell around the neighborhood very
dope
hey what's up boys I got a king at our
sting it for y'all but first do you look
like the guy that accepts tickets at the
entrance of a corn maze Brendan you look
like a guy that gets [ __ ] lost in the
corn maze so corn mazes
can't get a sting it love what you guys
are doing keep up the good work
buzz-buzz Gang Gang I like a corn maze
man it's a good way to spend time with
your family uh you can be outdoors you
can be at one with nature you can see
what nature can do you know some of the
you know things I'm thinking of geysers
waterfalls corn mazes just different
things where you get nature at its
fullest parameters I shut up get back in
your car dude okay get back in your car
so you at the gas station
okay second of all you was this guy's
name was Ethan
second of all Ethan yeah bro you're
gonna be fine dude yeah you mean find
you it's don't worry about crying all
the time
I just keep taking care of yourself dude
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah man
yester corn mazes but I like when they
you got someone there chase you're maybe
a an old convict some sort of guy that
needs money maybe an eagle yeah maybe a
big thick ego maybe a [ __ ] guy just
got a prison carrying a bunch of [ __ ]
cheeto puffs you know I'm saying that's
like a little danger though yeah that's
the best thing about a lot of haunted
houses they'll hire anybody so you do
get a lot of those type of a client you
know a worker client or a Perry makes
clientele where you should kid you have
a guy I [ __ ] hit you at a real sword
in there bro you know at some of those
high-end haunted place so they'll do it
you'll sign a waiver the do it yeah but
corn maze how about a pop corn maze dude
that'd be fun I've run through that
[ __ ] with my mouth open boy yeah you
know like cinnamon popcorn
yeah like it god that was my favorite is
the kid the red I like it I like car I
like a nice caramel corn I like it all
right I got Chicago popcorn uh-huh
Chicago popcorn shattered mixed with
hormones it's cheese popcorn mixed with
caramel popcorn mix it up yes okay oh
you're making a sound yeah oh you meant
doesn't go to Chicago get the popcorn
yep I love this guy I love what you're
doing but good luck you know the maze
last one boys this is Jay Cates from
Brighton Illinois it's big Jay Oh
beautiful area
what's up deal what's up Brendan this is
Jay from Illinois you share about double
check with you
we always can't be cool and hang out
with the cool people be swell
such finally get to be in your 40s
looking for some other stuff to do
hobbies that's one of those things man
ask a quick question
Kangin are staying at remote control
airplanes those RC headers you know I'm
saying gang stuff that you thought you
would have played with when he was just
a kid
Jesus Christ dude electric Eagles
Brendan love you guys love you too
brother man reaching out from bright and
beautiful field there you got yeah
that's a nice green field look at that
electric Eagle boy I feel like he gets
boring after a minute bro you see it
just came right by play freeze tag with
that thing well you hear your kid
touching yourself in an extra music
[ __ ] foot in his ass yeah are you
kids out in the garden hiding in a
wheelbarrow touching his own wiener you
buzz him with that hitter well I hit
that Mexican eagle at your [ __ ] zoo
Oh
oh yeah brother Sinaloa yeah take that
[ __ ] it go away don't a couple they
did the guy said they have a bunch of
not a bunch of birds but a decent amount
he said I bet it's the Mexican flamingo
I'm waiting I emailed him and Diane
Brown uh back then oh yeah they named
brown flamingos of the Sinaloa and zoo I
like that sound like a football team
right you've seen the Browns we got 12
of them yeah be cool one big thick one
calling big brown yeah no I said about
your coffee company did it alright or
adult hobbies as well just either one
yeah stay busy dude you know stay busy
or next thing you know you're on the
internet hating on people who are
successful so you gotta stay [ __ ]
busy or jacking off or touching yourself
or touching someone else you don't even
know that well why a man underage girls
you know so fly planes bro
[ __ ] flies yep I love what you're
doing here man you're out and about and
you're enjoying your life and you're
living it and that's what we got to do
dude it's what we got to do
let's go on let's do it let's do it on
keep touching me bro
[Music]